please
secretary blinken de Tony welcome to
Oslo welcome to this NATO foreign
ministerial meeting and we have many
issues to discuss but let me first of
all thank you for your personal
commitment your personal leadership and
at least everything in the United States
does to strengthen transatlantic Bond
and and to support Ukraine and our
support to Ukraine will be in one of the
main issues
then we also understand that the most
urgent and important to us now is to
ensure that Ukraine prevails uh because
it's only with an independent Sovereign
Ukraine in Europe that the membership
issue is something to address at all and
then we also understand and that uh this
will be an issue that we need to address
in one way or another when the war ends
we also discuss uh how to strengthen our
defense and defense including invest
more we should
regard a two percent not as a ceiling
but as a minimum a floor for our defense
Investments and then we will address how
to further strengthen our partnership
with the Asia Pacific partners and then
of course address also how we can
continue to make progress on the
ratification of Sweden to have Sweden as
a full-fledged member so once again Tony
it's good to have you here in the city
hall of Oslo and to have your also
please thank you yes thank you very much
it's wonderful to be in Oslo it's a it's
a minor coincidence that it happens to
be the secretary General's Hometown uh
so we're very pleased to be able to
share that as well but this is a very
important stop on the road to the
leaders Summit in Vilnius in just about
a little over a month's time and as the
Secretary General said and I can uh
really only reiterate and reaffirm what
he said we have an intense focus on the
support that we're continuing to provide
to Ukraine to make sure that it prevails
against the Russian aggression that's
now been going on for well over a year
to make sure as well that we continue to
strengthen our own defensive Alliance
through building up our plans for
deterrence and defense and as well to
continue the process of bringing new
members into the alliance notably Sweden
those are the top issues that will be on
the agenda in Vilnius in a few weeks
time very much the issues that are on
our agenda today to make sure that all
allies are are fully aligned as we head
into the leader Summit but I have no
doubt that will be the case one of the
stories of the last year and a half has
been the extraordinary Unity the
extraordinary solidarity of the NATO
alliance it's been very much one of the
principal reasons for the success that
Ukraine has had in pushing back against
the Russian aggression we have said from
day one what we would do in terms of
supporting Ukraine in terms of putting
pressure on Russia and in terms of
strengthening our own Alliance we have
done what we've said we'll continue to
do that this meeting and of course the
leaders Summit will be critical next
steps in that ongoing effort thank you
thank you